♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY,"
THE FAKE NEWS EPIDEMIC AND
TONIGHT FOR THE HOUR WE'RE GOING
MEDIA AND THEIR UNPRECEDENTED
ASSAULT AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TOP FAKE NEWS ANCHORS,
REPORTERS, THE BIGGEST
ANTI-TRUMP PRINT MEDIA OUTLETS
AND THE MOST INEXCUSABLE EXAMPLE
OF THE MEDIA IS SPREADING FAKE
NEWS TO YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE'LL SHOW YOU PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
MOST EPIC TAKEDOWNS OF THE
LIBERAL MAINSTREAM MEDIA, HE'S
FACED AN ONSLAUGHT OF HISTORIC
NEGATIVE MEDIA COVERAGE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST THESE ATTACKS
BY UNVEILING WHAT HE'S CALLED
THESE MOST DISHONEST CORRUPT
MEDIA AWARDS OF THE YEAR.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHOW YOU JUST
HOW ABUSIVELY BIASED TO THE
ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA IT REALLY IS
AND IT STARTS WITH THE MEDIA
SAYING THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD
NEVER WIN, NEVER BECOME THE
PRESIDENT, TAKE A LOOK.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING
HE WOULD RUN FOR PRESIDENT AS A
REPUBLICAN WHICH IS SURPRISING
BECAUSE I JUST ASSUMED HE WAS
RUNNING AS A JOKE.
>> DO IT.
DO IT.
I WILL PERSONALLY WRITE YOU A
CAMPAIGN CHECK NOW ON BEHALF OF
THIS COUNTRY WHICH DOES NOT WANT
YOU TO BE PRESIDENT BUT WHICH
BADLY WANTS YOU TO RUN.
>> THIS MAN HAS ITS OWN
MOMENTUM, WE BETTER BE READY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHICH REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
HAS THE BEST CHANCE OF WINNING
THE GENERAL ELECTION?
>> OF THE DECLARED ONES, RIGHT
NOW, DONALD TRUMP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MR. TRUMP, TO ANSWER YOUR
CALL FOR POLITICAL HONESTY, I
JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU'RE NOT
AS THE WORST PRESIDENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES, AT
REAL DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: AFTER HIS STUNNING
I MEAN LITERALLY CRYING.
THIS IS A SADNESS, IT IS A
MORNING MOMENT FOR THOSE PEOPLE.
IT IS A MOMENT FILLED WITH FEAR.
>> OUR COUNTRY IS ABOUT TO FACE
SOME SERIOUS CRISES.
BUCKLE UP, YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS
YOU.
>> PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY THING TO
SAY.
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
THE PEOPLE IN THE MILITARY
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION.
>> THIS WAS A WHITE LASH AGAINST
A CHANGING COUNTRY AGAINST A
BLACK PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA HAS DONE
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO TRY TO
DESPITE NO EVIDENCE.
LOOK AT THIS NONSTOP, SHAMEFUL
COVERAGE.
>> I THINK THIS IS A POTENTIALLY
MORE DANGEROUS SITUATION THEN
WATERGATE AND WE ARE AT A VERY
DANGEROUS MOMENT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM DURING AN ELECTION
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH A HOSTILE
FOREIGN POWER TO UNDERMINE THE
POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
THERE.
THE WHOLE RUSSIA THING.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT COLLUSION.
>> OUTRIGHT TREASON, THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT WHAT HE IS DOING
IS GIVING AID AND COMFORT TO THE
ENEMY.
>> I THINK IT MEANS THAT A
FEDERAL JUDGE FOUND THAT PEOPLE
IN HIS ORGANIZATION WERE
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> FIRST WE WANT TO START WITH
THIS WEEK IN RUSSIA-GATE.
RUSSIA.
>> THE CLOUD WILL HANG OVER HIM
NO WHERE HE STANDS.
>> IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE IN THE
OPENING STAGES OF A DEVASTATING
POLITICAL CHAPTER IN AMERICAN
PROBE.
>> IT'S AT THE CALIBER OF A
PEARL HARBOR OR EIGHT 9/11, DO
YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT THE
THRESHOLD OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> I THINK IT'S OVER, I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING THAT CAN
BE DONE THAT CAN STOP THIS AT
THIS POINT.
THIS GUSHING OF LIES, PROBLEMS,
QUESTIONS, CHAOS THAT WILL STOP
THIS PRESIDENT IN HIS TRACKS.
>> YOU TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST" LAST WEEK
THAT THERE IS A SMELL OF TREASON
IN THE AIR WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO
USE THE T-WORD, THAT'S WHAT
COLLUSION, IT DOES LOOK LIKE HE
IS LISTENING TO VLADIMIR PUTIN
MORE THAN HE IS AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE AND I'VE NEVER SEEN
THAT BEFORE.
>> Sean: PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SEBASTIAN
THEY WERE SHOCKED BY IT ALL, IT
WAS A FUNERAL ON NOVEMBER 8TH
2016.
EVER SINCE THERE HAS BEEN AN
EFFORT TO UNDO OR DELEGITIMIZE
IT GETS REALLY SERIOUS.
>> NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT
EXPECTED, ON THE NIGHT OF THE
ELECTION, HILLARY CLINTON HAS A
MORE THAN THE 95% CHANCE OF
WINNING.
THEY STILL CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
FOR ALL THIS TALK IN THE NEW
BOOK ABOUT THE MENTAL COMPETENCE
HEALTH?
ALL THE PEOPLE YOU JUST SHOWED
IN YOUR MONTAGE.
THEY NEED MENTAL HELP,
PROFESSIONALS TO HELP THEM.
I JUST HAD A JOURNALIST ASKED ME
TODAY BASED UPON THE MICHAEL
WOLFF BOOK, IS IT TRUE THAT THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T LIKE ANYONE
TOUCHING HIS TOOTHBRUSH?
THAT'S JOURNALISM.
NORTH KOREA HAS NUCLEAR MISSILES
NORTH KOREA HAS NUCLEAR MISSILE
MISSILES.
THE PRESIDENT DEFEATED ISIS.
CHINA IS ON THE MARCH AND THEY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S TOOTHBRUSH.
THIS IS A BAD SKIT, IT'S
INSANITY, HERMAN CAIN, YOU
EXPERIENCED THIS ALL FIRSTHAND.
YOU CAN SPEAK TO HOW BAD THIS IS
BUT IT'S STILL A LOT WORSE FOR
IN THAT OPENING MONTAGE WAS
FANTASTIC.
THE LIBERALS AND IT ALSO
INDICATES AS HE ALLUDED TO,
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME IS AN
ADDICTION BECAUSE RESULTS DON'T
MATTER.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
RESULTS OF 2017, IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
IF I CAN BORROW A METAPHOR FROM
MIKE HUCKABEE, ADDICTS THAT ARE
DRUG ADDICTS, SOME OF THEM
RECOVERED.
BUT THE MEDIA TDS ADDICTS, THEY
DIGGING AND THEY CAN'T GET OUT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS ILLUSTRATES AND
ON THE MEDIA TO GIVE US THE
TRUTH AND NOW WE KNOW IT THEY
CANNOT, THEY ARE INCAPABLE OF
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA, IT'S BEEN
THE YEAR OF TRYING TO GET HIM
OUT OF OFFICE.
TO DELEGITIMIZE, THE WORDS, THE
ADJECTIVES THAT ARE USED ON AN
HOURLY BASIS ON CABLE TV AND
SUPPOSEDLY HARD NEWS
JOURNALISTIC CENTERS, ABC, CBS,
NBC IS THE WORST --
"WASHINGTON POST,"
"NEW YORK TIMES" THAT THEY USED
>> THEY ARE HURTING THE WHOLE
COUNTRY, THIS IS THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT FOR THE MOST
POWERFUL NATION IN THE WORLD AND
THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE THAT HE IS
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY USE THE KIND OF LANGUAGE
OUTRAGEOUS FOR A BLOGGER TO DO
ON MAINSTREAM TELEVISION.
THE GOOD NEWS IS FOX NEWS IS
CRUSHING IT WITH THREE,
4 MILLION VIEWERS PER NIGHT.
ANDERSON COOPER CRACKS OPEN A
BOTTLE OF CHAMPAGNE OF 600,000
PEOPLE WATCHING.
THEY ARE BECOMING IRRELEVANT.
I AM AN AMERICAN CITIZEN NOW AND
I'M PROUD TO BE.
YOU KNOW WHAT DEFINES US?
COMMON SENSE.
WHEN YOU GET OUT OF THE BUBBLE,
THEY COULDN'T CARE LESS ABOUT
MICHAEL WOLFF FOR DON LEMON,
THEY WANT TO SEE THEIR PAYCHECK
IN FEBRUARY BE BIGGER THAN IT
WAS IN JANUARY, THEY WANT TO SEE
ICE IS CRUSHED.
THEY WANT TO SEE THROUGH THE
LIES AND THEY TUNE INTO THE DOOR
SHOW THAT'S GREAT NEWS.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
IT THIS IS THE YEAR OF THE
BOOMERANG?
NOW WE KNOW THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION IS AND HAS BEEN FOUR
MONTHS INVESTIGATED, WHICH IT
SHOULD BE.
SERVER SCANDAL.
WE KNOW THAT COMEY RIGGED THAT
INVESTIGATION OF MONTHS BEFORE
WRITING BEFORE AN EXONERATION
LETTER -- ALL OF THESE THINGS
NOW AND TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION
DYING OUT -- IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S BEEN A DRAMATIC TURN OF
EVENTS THAT THE MEDIA NEVER
EXPECTED TO.
WITH A LOOK AT HILLARY CLINTON
FUNDING A DOSSIER ARE FULL OF
LIES, RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA, AND
SALACIOUS MATERIAL AND SAY THAT
COULD BE COLLUSION?
WASN'T USED FOR A FISA WARRANT?
THIS IS ALL FLIPPED ON THEM.
>> THEY WILL NEVER ADMIT IT.
REMEMBER, THE CASE ON
HILLARY CLINTON WAS CLOSED
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IT HAS NOW BEEN REOPENED UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
EVEN THOUGH JEFF SESSIONS GETS A
LOT OF CRITICISM, I HAPPEN TO
BELIEVE BASED UPON ALL OF THE
REPORTS AND INFORMATION THAT WE
KNOW AND BASED UPON THE OUTRAGE
HILLARY IS GOING DOWN.
ONLY ONE STRATEGY AND IT WAS
USED DECADES AGO.
IF YOU KEEP TELLING A LIE OFTEN
ENOUGH, OVER AND OVER AND OVER,
SOONER OR LATER SOME PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BELIEVE IT.
THE THING IS MOST OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY BELIEVING THE
LIE ARE ALREADY BELIEVING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONSERVATIVE
VOICES OUT THERE, EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE OUTNUMBERED, I TRULY BELIEVE